hey everyone might guy secure normally
this time this week we would have
another gadget lab podcast episode for
you but as you know Steve Jobs the
founder of Apple passed away on
wednesday there's been a huge outpouring
of emotion across the world twitter
exploded with rest and peace Steve Jobs
messages people are going to apple
stores in London and Japan and leaving
candlelight vigils or bouquets of
flowers dedicated to Steve's memory
they've been tributes from Sergey Brin
of Google to Mark Zuckerberg to former
rival Bill Gates even President Obama's
and his condolences to steve's family
how was it that one man was able to
affect so many people in such a short
amount of time I think it was because
steve was essentially a product guy at
heart everything that came out of Apple
had his stamp of approval on it and
nothing was ever good enough it had to
be perfect and you know Steve's design
ideas apples design ideas were very
clear Apple under Steve's influence
produced some amazing products
everything from Apple's first computer
which Steve and his partner was built in
there Palo Alto garage to the ipod the
first ipod ten years ago to last year's
ipad which basically changed the way we
interact with physical media on a daily
basis i remember getting my first ipod
at Christmas time it was a it was this
sort of big white brick that essentially
did away with my CDs you know and any
cassettes that I had I no longer had to
to carry that around with me now the
ipod is something that we sort of take
for granted you know it's like our car
keys or a wallet or or something that we
don't leave the house without so as a
tribute we decided we go around the
office and ask some of the folks at
Wired how Steve is affected their lives
I'm Michael colori i'm the product
reviews editor on wired.com my dad
brought home a mac I must have been
about nine or 10 maybe 11 years old I
think it was a Mac 512 he brought it
home from the office and he brought it
upstairs into the family room and
plunked it on the table and said Michael
tell me what you think of this and I
spent hours with it playing with the
mouse I've never seen a mouse before I
got really into it and then it
disappeared he took it back to work but
around that time we also got an apple to
see which was sort of the portable apple
and I spent a lot of my youth in front
of that machine in front of the
monochrome display playing a conan video
game karateka wizardry Ultima 4 and of
course like text based games like zork
and Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy but
of course I also use it to write my
first papers as a student I wrote my
first programs on it and it's the thing
that is most responsible for getting me
into into computers i bought a modem for
it I went online that opened up a whole
new world to me come full circle however
many years later I just bought my mom an
ipad for her birthday this year and she
loves it and it's amazing the same
company was able to make both devices it
you know sort of both ends of the
timeline for me my name is Christina
Bonnington I'm a staff writer with
Wired's Gadget Lab blog i've been using
macs since i was a kid but the first
apple product that i ever actually owned
was an ipod mini i got it as a gift in
2005 from my boyfriend at the time it
was a Valentine's Day gift the ipod mini
was the first ipod to have the click
wheel and mine was blue and it was
engraved on the back with a latin quote
i don't remember
what it said no but I was a ballet
dancer at the time and so I stretched
every day before class for 30 to 45
minutes and I was doing that in silence
every day and once I got my ipod I could
listen to music and it just really
brought music into my life I got my
first ipod in probably two thousand five
I had just finished the last of many
many internships and I was unemployed
and I decided that I was going to go
backpacking in Europe and the only way I
could think to do that was to be to take
an iPod with me I was the only way I
could take my music and so I spent an
entire month writing trains listening to
my ipod and it was the only thing that
kind of I don't know can be connected to
home because I could have all my my
music with me and I have this memory of
going to the Louvre like one of the last
days I was in Europe and walking through
the main corridor listening to I'm
loving it by Justin Timberlake and it
was kind of the best thing in that one
moment when I'm just like listening to
my favorite song you know having this
thing I felt like one of those people
against a pink screen like a black
silhouette and an apple ad and I had
that moment of being like this is what
they meant this is that moment they want
you to have in that stupid commercial
and so it was just you know I didn't
think about it much after the fact but
now that you know we've lost Steve I was
thinking about it and a lot of people
talk about how he's enabled people to
interact with technology in a way that's
much more personal and now when I think
back on that I think like I understand
how what his impact was in that it
allowed you to have experiences like
that with technology that probably
weren't there before the first computer
I ever owned was an apple 2 plus i was
13 years old and i had saved my money
over a year of running a paper route and
delivering papers around the
neighborhood i finally had enough money
with a little help from my dad i bought
an apple 2 plus was the first personal
computer i had ever owned and we were
only the second people I'd ever known
who had
computer in their house I learned how to
program on that thing I learned how to
get onto bulletin boards eventually I
wrote some games and some interactive
stuff I love that computer it was like
an it was my introduction to technology
and it was the first point at which i
realized that technology opened up a
whole new Vista for me it's it's
actually pretty astonishing to think of
what Apple has done in such a short span
of time to change video games I mean you
know I'm a gamer I play console games
and pc games and I know lots of other
people who do too and we would have
never played mobile phone games we would
have never taken out our mobile phone
with its number keypad and played games
on it but as we all started getting
iphones the craziest thing happened you
know apples approach to development in
the App Store and letting people make
games and sell games you know without
having to go through all of these layers
and all these processes and just you
know connecting us with game creators
suddenly we had a pocket full of really
fantastic video games that you couldn't
get anywhere else and this this has
absolutely changed the industry i mean
the industry the video game industry is
still in just this tremendous amount of
upheaval right now because of what Apple
did and I don't even think Apple was
trying to change the video games
industry they just created a product
that was so amazingly forward-thinking
and so disruptive to the process of what
the entrenched big companies were doing
that they that they changed video games
without even meaning to and now when
Apple gets up at its press conference is
it it talks about how the iphone is one
of the biggest video game players out
there and this is very interesting to
think they they had never really meant
to do that but when they realized what
it was they were doing they they jumped
on it and you know that was all down to
two Steve Jobs singular you know vision
of what the iphone was going to be and
how it was going to connect people to
content so in the late 90s I was the
editor-in-chief of a magazine called Mac
addict and I came to the magazine right
about the same time that Steve Jobs
return to apple and the thing that
people don't remember about those days
is Steve Jobs return to apple was not
something everybody was comfortable with
even Macintosh fans there's a lot of
people nervous about what he would do it
the company and in rapid succession he
ousted Gil Amelio he killed the Newton
and he discontinued the clones and
people were really freaking out people
loved the Newton and people thought the
clones were apples one ticket to
possibly holding on so people were
really afraid of what Steve Jobs was
doing he was being very brash and I'm
writing an op-ed piece basically arguing
hey Steve's great you know we should you
know give him time you know he's the
founder we got to give him a little bit
of space to do some things here you guys
are freaking out too quickly but people
were very scared that Apple was going to
go under under him but then the original
iMac came out and it just blew
everybody's minds and reshaped what we
expected from a computer and then people
just turned the corner of on Steve Jobs
and we're like okay you know they went
from saying like is this the right guy
to when is he going to drop interim for
the from from his CI CEO title and then
you know he just continued with a string
of products of string of great hardware
and beautiful products and then the real
coupe de Grace was the ipod and once
that came out there was no question you
know Steve Jobs was the man so yeah I
came into the Steve Jobs Apple sphere
relatively early in life I was about 11
or 12 and my grandmother got me computer
lessons and so I was coding on an apple
too way back in the day and then when i
was in college i had my first
interactions with the macintosh and that
kind of changed everything i was a you
know i was a liberal arts english major
but I was always designing and doing
this kind of stuff and when I got out of
college even though my degree was in
English I was a graphic designer and
that's what I did for years um and was
an apple die hard I mean I had an I
brake for eight bumper sticker on my car
with 40 s eight I was you know way way
down the whole even these are in the
Scully years um and when jobs came back
an apple was reimbursing I was I mean I
was excited about this I felt like I had
a personal stake even though
aside from buying these products but
there was just this emotional connection
with the way the things worked and what
they enabled me to do and the sort of
upstart vibe around Apple back then
obviously they're not like that now but
having been involved with them from the
start to when they almost vanish to
coming back I just I felt like I had
this personal stake in things and
because of the interactions of the
Macintosh I my work in publishing now
and I think if it hadn't been the case
i'd probably be a high school teacher or
something now so for an IT guy for a
tech person he is to me what Spielberg
is to you he's he's a genius that gets
it and can talk to regular people about
it but when he's talking to other tech
people it makes sense on a different
level I'm sure you get what I'm saying
with that because when Spielberg is
talking to other movie people he's
talking on a level that most people have
no idea what he's talking about but he
can turn around and talk to talk to
somebody from CNN and everyone gets it
that was one of Steve Jobs greatest
talents and that's one of the reasons
why I wanted to get into support is
being able to translate well this is
what's going on with a computer to
people that don't get it and 19 before
my family got the first computer a
family computer and it was an apple
macintosh and I was 14 years old and I
was a lonely queer teenager and so I
would sneak into my dad's office when
they didn't know and I go into those AOL
chatrooms looking for like other queer
people online so the kind of that
experience prompted a short film when i
made fifteen years later about that and
ever since then I've been an Apple user
no a media maker and I was like maybe I
would have been something like a doctor
but no now I'm a media maker who works
at Wired magazine thanks Steve Jobs
you're basically the reason I'm here
today thank you very much you inspired
me and a whole generation of people
around me hi I'm Steve Jobs every once
in a while a revolutionary product comes
along that changes everything today
we're introducing three revolutionary
products of this class and I would like
to take the privilege of showing you
what they're going to look like but
before we get to that I want to go back
to nineteen seventy-seven Apple a young
fledgling company on the west coast
invents the Apple to the first personal
computer as we know it today IBM
dismisses the personal computer as too
small to do serious computing and
unimportant to their business 1984 now
I'd like to show you Macintosh in person
they wrote embed in dog in 2001 the
choice we made was music now why music
well we love music and it's always good
to do something you love and that
product is called ipod today Apple is
going to reinvent the phone you got to
see this thing in person but I'll do the
best I can with video this is imac the
whole thing is translucent you can see
into it it's so cool and we'd like to
show it to you today for the first time
and we call it the ipad that's what it
looks like very thick it's so thin it
even fits inside one of these envelopes
that we've all seen floating around the
office
this is the new macbook air a few weeks
ago we announced a user downloaded the
three billion 'the application from the
app store now something very exciting
it's my pleasure today to announce Mac
OS
there's an old Wayne Gretzky quote that
I love I skate to where the puck is
going to be not where it has been and
we've always tried to do that at Apple
since the very very beginning and we
always will so thank you very very much
but we're not done yet because I'd like
to let Macintosh speak for itself sure
it is Miss considerable pride that I
introduce a man who's been like a father
to lead speed
you